Justice League is finally here the movie
in which Batman the flash cyborg Wonder
Woman and Aquaman team up to fight
against Steppenwolf
we've already had movies with Wonder
Woman and Batman in the DC extended
universe but this is the first time
we're really getting a good look at the
flash Aquaman and Cyborg as most people
know this film went under a very
difficult production when Zack Snyder's
daughter tragically committed suicide he
had to step away from the production and
Joss Whedon came in and did very
extensive reshoots and rewrites
henry cavill was working on Mission
Impossible 6 at the time and had a
mustache that they had to digitally
remove for all of said reshoots because
I guess a ton of reshoots and rewrites
is just the Hollywood norm nowadays so
how is Justice League well I can say
this it's it's definitely a lot more
consistent than I thought it would be
for a film that is kind of directed by
two people it does feel like one person
directed this movie it's more consistent
than I thought rogue one was in tone
then certainly more consistent than
Suicide Squad but it doesn't really feel
like a Zack Snyder movie and I've seen
all of his films this is the least zack
snyder EO of all of the films that I've
seen him direct and that could be for
one of two things it could be that he
has decided that he's going to make a
more lighthearted film with a little
less baggage or Joss Whedon has more of
a stamp on this film than we're being
led to believe whatever the reason this
is a surprisingly light-hearted movie I
would even go as far as to say it's a
little fluffy and I'm not really
necessarily saying that's a bad thing
this is a easy enjoyable wash it's two
hours in one minute and that's including
credits this is due to a mandate that
was sent out by Warner Brothers forcing
the filmmakers to not make a film over
two hours this can also be difficult
with this movie because we're trying to
introduce people like cyborg and the
flash and Aquaman characters that were
only briefly referenced and sometimes
briefly seen in other DC EU movies and
so they have to set up this team somehow
get Superman back into play and set up
Steppenwolf and have an actual movie
that makes sense
in two hours and due to that this movie
can feel rushed character intros
especially for people like the flash
we've basically seen his character intro
in the very first trailer it's so brief
he's very excited to work with this team
because he doesn't have any friends he
doesn't have anything else to do it's
funny it's very Barry Allen and I
thought Ezra Miller was great as the
flash
I've been waiting ever since I was a kid
to see the flash in a big screen movie
so it was a huge delight to see the
flash brought to life so well by Ezra
Miller and some terrific special effects
the Speed Force was extremely exciting
and Aquaman was entertaining I liked
Jason Momoa quite a bit as the character
I thought he was funny he was likable
and that's definitely the vibe they're
going for here they are trying to do a
course correction and be a little less
serious and try to be more lighthearted
and more fun and that's very clear when
you watch this movie because as I said
it is a little fluffy and when I say
that I just mean that it's just kind of
easy to watch and it doesn't feel like
you're carrying anything with you while
you do it which can also make the film
feel a little disposable once you've
seen it and some of this is due to
Steppenwolf they try to take time to set
up Steppenwolf and make you understand
his backstory there's an excellent
sequence onthe mascara where he is
trying to obtain one of the mother boxes
and all of the Amazonian warriors are
trying to keep him away from it it's one
of the best action scenes and one of the
most exciting action scenes in the movie
but as a villain I found him very weak
because he's basically a big CGI monster
in this movie and you never really feel
as if he is a presence or something
really to fear because this movie is
very light hearted and that can be a big
problem the sense of urgency the sense
of fear the sense of realism is pretty
much out the window you don't really
feel like this is actually something
you're supposed to be afraid of
Steppenwolf he's such a CGI creation and
he's so weak from a characterization
point of view that I never really gave a
shit about him during the finale they're
all battling in this sort of ghost town
were not too many people live but there
are a fair amount of people there they
make that clear but they choose to only
show one family throughout the entire
film they constantly cut back to this
family and you see they have kids and a
mom and a dad and it's just this one
family that you see and so you never
really feel like people are in danger
they only focus on this one family
through
the entire finale and so you just don't
really feel like anyone's in real danger
it's just a really pretty movie and you
can be excited while watching really
awesome superhero stuff happen and I'm
not saying that in a derogatory sense I
like me some superheroes I have my
entire life and so anytime I can see
some of my childhood heroes quite
literally battling it out on the screen
I'm excited to be there and I was
excited to see Justice League and I
think overall this is an enjoyable watch
I wouldn't say it's a complete course
correction but I would say it's a step
in the right direction
it is very rushed though as I said for
instance cyborg betrayed by ray Fisher
very well I might add I think ray Fisher
as good as this character he is one of
the most difficult characters to get
across here because his backstory is
very murky in the film I mean I know
what it is in the comics but I have to
always separate that I have to realize
that this is a movie and the majority of
the audience that goes to this movie
like the general public who just wants
to go see the Justice League they
probably haven't read too many of the
comics and so here we get some hints and
some backstory explained as to what
happened but cyborgs position on this
team just basically ends up being the
guy who interacts with things he touches
things he reads technical readouts and
he tells people what they need to know
and he doesn't really do that much he
has an integral thing that he has to do
and he has to be there to make something
work but just because he stands there
interacting with something for ten
straight minutes it's just not very
exciting and I wish that cyborg had more
to do than just be the guy who reads
files and touches things gal gadot as
Wonder Woman of course is great I loved
her film she was one of my favorite
parts of this movie as well Ben Affleck
once again really strong as Batman and
Bruce Wayne I've been on his side since
before BBS even came out and he was
great once again Henry Cavill as
Superman this is my favorite Superman
has ever been in the DC EU when he
appears it's so awesome they really did
some cool stuff with Superman and I
won't give you any spoilers away but the
things that they did it really made me
happy as a longtime Superman fan
and I think most Superman fans are gonna
be happy with the way he's portrayed
here and yeah in a few shots you can
definitely tell the mustache has been
digitally removed but I wonder if he
really would have known if it wasn't so
widely purported because everything now
involving comic-book movies or Star Wars
is a news article or a clickbait
headline and so I if we didn't know we
might not notice but now that we know
you can kind of look in a few shots and
be like that's definitely a cgi upper
lip but it's not the kind of thing that
would tank a movie it's just noticeable
in a few scenes but again my biggest
issue with this film is that it does
feel rushed and I think if you delete
the production issues and just not even
think about that I think I would boil it
down to Warner Brothers mandate that it
has to be two hours or less because
there's so much they're trying to do
here and they don't have enough time to
do it Barry Allen's setup is very very
small as is Cyborg's they just don't
give you enough time to really
appreciate some of these characters and
they're entertaining they're likable
they save funny things and so you can
kind of get behind them and appreciate
watching this but there just wasn't as
much depth in the team as I wish there
could have been when you have to put
certain things into a movie to set up
other films and that's the only reason
it really fits into this movie you're
gonna get into some messy plot points
and you're gonna get into some things
that don't really work and that's the
biggest issue of all cinematic universes
something else I would have liked to
have seen is a little more squabbling
amongst the team more character
confrontations things that they
disagreed on because the scenes in which
characters on the Justice League fought
or disagreed I thought were some of the
best in the entire film but it's brushed
over so quickly to get to everyone
battling Steppenwolf and a big red green
screen area and I wish that there was
just more character confrontations
because that would give us more depth on
the team it would give us more reasons
to feel like they are separate entities
trying to work together not just one big
team that has one goal I think where you
can tell the most that two different
people have directed this movie and that
there's been rewrites is that scenes
don't always flow with a natural
momentum
scenes come and go and they feel like
contained moments like a clip you might
watch on YouTube that's really cool like
ooh I want to watch that scene where
Batman does that or I want to watch that
scene where flash does this and it
doesn't always feel like it creates a
whole picture and this is the kind of
thing that I have to remember because
I'm such a huge fan of all these
characters but I'm also someone who
loves to examine film and this is not a
comic book you know I know a lot of
these characters backstories and I can
look at this movie and I can fill in the
gaps that are not in the movie I can say
well I understand what Steppenwolf is
doing here because I know what they're
hinting it or I understand why that
person's in the movie because I know
what they're hinting at or oh that's
cool they did that because I remember
that from issue whatever but most people
who go to this film aren't going to
connect those dots and so some people
will go to this movie and be a little
murky on plot details and not quite
understand what certain characters are
talking about or what Steppenwolf is
trying to do and that's understandable
and I have to recognize that as a huge
comic book fan but also as a huge film
fan because there's two differences here
and this is one of the biggest issues
that I think any film adapted from any
source material whether it's a novel a
video game or a comic book has to face
is how can we tell this story for an
audience that has no idea who these
characters are except for what they know
from pop culture and justice league has
some issues with that
I think hardcore comics fans are going
to get and appreciate a lot of the
references more than general audiences
will and since I love comics and I love
these characters I found myself smiling
for the most part this is a movie that I
have enjoyed a lot more than some of the
other DC EU films I think that it is
light-hearted and entertaining but it
doesn't really feel like it sticks with
you that much it is a little bit
disposable in the long run I can say
that overall I have breached the gap and
I am on the positive side here but it
still got a lot of work and if there is
an extended version it could improve
some things because I don't really look
at this movie and see one giant glaring
flaw it's just totally very messy and it
feels like a lot of thing
are happening at once and it's villain
is very very weak he's just a big strong
guy that punches things and beyond that
you can't really get that much more out
of him but it's the chemistry between
these actors the camaraderie amongst
them all the dedication from all of them
as well as the fact that this movie
understands that this is supposed to be
entertaining this is supposed to be
exciting for people who have wanted to
see this for a long time and it also is
a little bit self-aware certain
characters that wouldn't normally tell a
joke do and that might be Whedon
sometimes he likes to do that with comic
book characters that are very macho
he likes to kind of bring them down to
earth a little bit and have them say
something humorous and you're like okay
that's a person behind that mask and
that works all that being said it is a
little sad though that to make a film
that it seems like more people are going
to enjoy than the others they had to
make it a little more disposable so I'm
curious what that actually says about
comic book movies can you have it both
ways can you make a comic book movie
that's very serious and yet somehow
still be very entertaining yes you can
we've seen it done but have we gotten so
saturated with comic book films at this
point that we need one to be kind of
fluffy to appreciate just something to
think about I'm gonna give Justice
League a b-minus I plan on seeing this
one again I'm not gonna rush out and see
it instantly but I do think that they
are heading in a good direction guys
thank you so much as always for watching
as always if you liked this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]